but first white house correspondent
peter ducey leads us off tonight
live from the north lawn good evening
peter good evening brett this isn't like
the times that president biden has tried
to address covet 19 or
immigration where lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle
understand what the problem is because
right now the biden white house
and republicans in congress have totally
different ideas
about the definition of infrastructure
everybody around the world is investing
billions and billions of dollars in
infrastructure
we're going to do it here without
republican support in the proposal's
current form
what the president proposed this week is
not
an infrastructure bill it's a huge
tax increase for one thing and it's a
tax increase
on small businesses on job creators
in the united states of america the
white house claims they're all
ears we hope members will be proposing
ideas republican senator roy blunt has
got one
i think there's an easy win here for
the white house if they would take that
win which is make this an infrastructure
package which is about 30 percent
if even if you stretch the definition of
infrastructure
some it's about 30 percent of the 2.25
trillion dollars they're talking about
spending
that's where there's a fundamental split
along party lines
infrastructure is not just the roads we
get a horse and buggy across
infrastructure according to the
president is a lot bigger i'm talking
about making sure that you take asbestos
out of school
that's infrastructure we're talking
about high-speed rail that's
infrastructure
cabinet members have already placed more
than 56 calls to lawmakers
selling the plan this is a once in a
lifetime moment and
paying for the proposal means raising
the corporate tax rate
i'm afraid that the highest tax will
drive corporations to other countries
not at all the white house wants to
raise the corporate tax rate from
21 percent to 28 democrat senator joe
manchin
says he wants less of a hike to 25
percent
if i don't vote to get on and it's not
going anywhere
so we're going to have some leverage
here and there's nothing it's more than
just me hopping
there's six or seven other democrats
that feel very strongly about this
the white house says they're unfazed we
fully expect that from senator manchin
and other members
if there's any horse trading happening
it is away
from cameras and reporters i'm not going
to negotiate with you on that
and president biden's favorite
non-partisan projections to site
are from moody's it is an organization
that members of his team have been
citing
as well as they start to sell the
american jobs
plan and they are very careful in
speaking to white house officials this
evening
to say they think the plan would help
create
19 million jobs over 10 years not
necessarily that the plan itself
creates 19 million jobs but that it
would help create
that many brett on this with a moment in
a moment peter ducey love the north lawn
peter thanks